mylan the drug company that created
outrage with the dramatic price increase
of the EpiPen is on the defensive this
morning a new report shows a big rise in
complaints about the device not working
in life-threatening emergencies
Bloomberg says 228 people this year
reported failures of EpiPen which
injects a drug that can cause severe
allergic reactions that's up from 2012
when just four failures were reported
Tony Jacopo's shows us one family scary
experience in Milan response to the
reports Tony good morning good morning
Milan doesn't take issue with the data
but says Bloomberg's article is
misleading it says a rise in reports of
failures doesn't necessarily mean a rise
in actual failures and suggests
heightened attention on the company and
increased prescriptions could be to
blame of course for those who depend on
the device any failure is unacceptable
watching your child's that-there
screamed - you don't let me die is awful
for any parent has to go through tina
hamptons moment of panic was made worse
after she reach for an EpiPen this past
spring her six-year-old daughter whom
she doesn't want on camera was gasping
for breath after an allergic reaction to
peanuts and when I pulled out the needle
did not go back inside of the EpiPen it
was bent it sliced her daughter's leg
leaving a scar she credits a backup
EpiPen for saving her child's life
Bloomberg obtained data from the FDA
linking 228 reports of EpiPen failures
to 7 deaths and 35 hospitalizations this
year the FDA cautions that with its
reporting system there is no certainty
that the reported event was due to the
product it's a very easy device to use
but someone in the panic might use it
wrong dr. Scott Fischer is a pediatric
allergy xpress he showed us how quickly
the EpiPen poised one two three
slow motion gives a better look at how
it delivers a dose of epinephrine just
one shot per device in emergencies he
says some folks get confused holding it
the wrong way when they press it they
then get the medication into their thumb
despite the increase in reports of
failures since 2012
Milan says no changes have been made to
the EpiPen device since 2009 the company
says they haven't found a causal
connection between reported patient
deaths and the EpiPen now there was a
recall of some epi pens earlier this
year due to a defective part but the FDA
tells us we are not aware of defective
epi pens currently on the market and
recommend that consumers use their
prescribed epinephrine auto-injector now
as for Tina Hampton the mom at the
beginning who had the scar on her
daughter's leg
she has switched to a competing injector
she used a backup she had a backup so
the pen still worked ultimately but if
there's been some confusion there might
be something that EpiPen take another
look at all right can I just say the
wedding ring looks very good on you
well thank you very much welcome back I
appreciate it I'm a very lucky man yes
you are Tony thank you very much